problema número 195 benito va a caminar
desde la intersección x al ayer es decir
desde este punto a este punto que se
muestra en este mapa
aquí hay calles y avenidas
antes rutas hay de quizás que tienen una
distancia mínima para que benito no
pierda el tiempo en el camino pensemos
de esta manera que caminos diferentes
hay para llegar a los puntos de esta
gráfica vamos a comenzar por este para
llegar a este punto de a partir de equis
pues sólo hay un camino no hay otra
forma de llegar acá
lo mismo sucede con este punto de acá
solo tengo un camino para llegar aquí
ahora por ejemplo que necesita para
llegar a este camino acá
bueno puedo llegar desde esta parte aquí
o desde esta otra entonces para este
tengo dos caminos con los que pueda
llegar cuántos caminos tengo para llegar
a este punto bueno tengo este y éste
sigue siendo un camino el punto de aquí
arriba pues también nada más tengo un
camino para llegar aquí aquí nada más
tengo uno ahora para el punto que se
encuentra aquí bueno en este punto puedo
llegar por acá que tenía un camino pero
también puedo llegar por acá y aquí
podría llegar yo a su vez mediante dos
caminos entonces sumo estos dos caminos
de acá más el camino de acá y resulta
que aquí tengo tres caminos con los que
puedo llegar la misma lógica sigue para
este punto de acá
que puedo llegar por acá que es igual a
un camino y también puedo llegar de este
lado que es dos caminos a su vez para
llegar aquí dos más uno
tengo tres caminos para este punto ahora
para llegar a este punto sigue siendo un
camino con un camino aquí y que hoy para
llegar a este punto puedo llegar por
este camino que a su vez hay tres
caminos por donde puedo llegar a este
punto y aquí hay un camino
uno más tres son cuatro y qué pasa acá
bueno aquí puedo llegar de este lado que
viene de tres caminos diferentes y este
otro lado que también tiene tres caminos
diferentes tres los tres son seis ahora
si finalmente el lugar que me interesa
llegar al punto y puedo llegar por este
lado que tiene cuatro caminos lo puede
llegar por este otro que tiene 66 más 4
son 10 tengo 10 caminos diferentes por
los que puedo llegar de equis allí y
esta va a ser mi opción c
el siguiente problema en una solución
la proporción por valor de jabón alcohol
y agua es de 2 a 50 a 100
esta solución se altera de manera que la
proporción jabón alcohol es el doble
mientras que la de jabón agua es la
mitad si la solución esperada contiene
100 centímetros cúbicos de alcohol
cuántos centímetros cúbicos de agua
habrá anotemos los datos que nos dan la
proporción de jabón
y alcohol lo habré veo como el agua es
así le escribo completa porque es
palabra cortita
es 2 a 50 a 100
nos dicen que se modifica la fórmula y
nos queda que la proporción jabón a
alcohol va a ser el doble de la anterior
doble y que la proporción de jabón y
agua
va a ser la mitad de la anterior o de la
original la mitad también nos dicen que
hay 100 centímetros cúbicos
alcohol
alcohol y nos preguntan de agua cuatro
centímetros cúbicos habrá pensemos en la
nueva proporción de jabón alcohol la
original nos decían que de jabón a
alcohol
2 a 50 y ahora está se va a duplicar
entonces la nueva proporción que le voy
a poner en otro color la nueva
proporción va a ser 4 entre 50 la
proporción anterior de jabón y agua
la original era de 2 haciendo 2 100 y
nos dicen que el actual es la mitad de
esto entonces va a ser en lugar de 2
entre 100 va a ser uno entre 100
veamos si podemos escribir todo esto
esto como quiero dejarlo todo diciendo
que la proporción en 4
voy a multiplicarlo y dividirlo entre 4
me va a quedar a 4 entre 400 y ahora
puedo escribir esto la nueva fórmula
como la proporción de jabón 4 a alcohol
50 a agua 400 nos dan al alcohol y nos
preguntan el agua la razón de alcohol a
agua
ya que lo tenemos así es igual a 50 de
qué es lo mismo que tener alcohol / agua
igual a 50 entre 400 que esto es lo
mismo a un octavo
nos dan el alcohol 100 centímetros
cúbicos tenemos entonces el alcohol con
son 100
el agua es nuestra incógnita
y esto es igual a 1 entre 8 bueno está
muy sencillo despejamos el agua y el
agua nos queda que es igual
a 8% 800 centímetros cúbicos que es la
opción el siguiente problema si el 75
por ciento de una clase responde
correctamente en la primera pregunta de
un examen el 55 por ciento responde
correctamente a la segunda y el 20% lo
respondió correctamente ambas preguntas
qué porcentaje respondió correctamente a
ambas preguntas
vamos a tratar de graficar la
información de esta manera tenemos que
de la primera pregunta el 75% que es lo
mismo que tener tres cuartas partes
respondieron bien o correctamente a la
primera pregunta
y esto se da entonces quiere decir que
una cuarta parte del grupo no respondió
bien a la primera pregunta una cuarta
parte tuvo mal la primera pregunta nos
dicen que una quinta parte o 20% no
tuvieron correctas ambas preguntas así
que de que tuvieron mal la primera
pregunta y tuvieron mal la segunda
pregunta es una quinta parte o el 20%
que tuvieron mal
estas preguntas
mi pregunta es si esta quinta parte es
el 20 por ciento de toda la población
qué porcentaje corresponde a esta cuarta
parte que respondieron mal la primera
pregunta vamos a llamar a esto yo
escribo bien mi p voy a expresar esto
como x por una cuarta parte es igual a
un quinto este es mi x qué parte de los
que respondieron más la primera pregunta
también respondieron más la segunda x me
va a quedar si la despejó x va a ser
igual a cuatro quintos es decir de todas
las personas que respondieron mal a la
primera pregunta cuatro quintos también
respondieron mal a la segunda esto nos
va a ayudar a encontrar la proporción de
los que respondieron mal en la primera
pero respondieron bien a la segunda
pregunta ok entonces de estos tenemos
que cuatro quintas partes respondieron
mal
de esto si cuatro quintas partes
respondieron mal la segunda pregunta
pues entonces una quinta parte
respondieron bien
la segunda pregunta
los datos nos dicen que 75 respondieron
bien a la pregunta 1 y 55 respondió bien
a la pregunta 2 a esta parte de los que
respondieron bien a la pregunta 1 hay
algunos que respondieron bien a la
segunda pregunta y otros que
respondieron mal a la segunda pregunta
de estos entonces aquí tengo que
respondieron bien a la pregunta 2 y los
que respondieron mal
a la pregunta 2
esto de acá yo lo quiero llamar
y voy a usar la variable x aunque es
diferente no es esta x ahora voy a
llamar x a este valor de acá x va a ser
esto cuál es la proporción total de
personas que tuvieron un mal la primera
pregunta y bien la segunda pregunta
quedamos claro quinta parte de un cuarto
es una veinteava parte esto es igual a 1
entre 20
un quinto por un cuarto un veinteavo de
toda la población sigue representa a los
que tuvieron bien ambas preguntas
entonces yemas x será el total de las
personas que respondieron bien a la
segunda pregunta entonces ya más x que
sólo entre 20 va a ser igual a 55 por
ciento que es 55 entre 100 esto lo puedo
simplificar como 11 20 a vos
y entonces ya con esto cuál es el valor
de g que va a ser igual a 11 20 amos
menos un veinteavo pues va a ser igual a
10 entre 20
qué es lo mismo que un medio así que la
mitad de la población tuvieron bien
ambas preguntas y esta es mi opción de
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo